do you know where the handshake came
from the handshake came from showing you
have no weapon I show you we may not
know each other but I show you we have
no weapon and out of that came the clasp
to say I don't have a weapon either and
two men with no weapons can say Okay
truce peace right I said what if I see
him in my garage and we're like oh and
I'm not quite sure but he's talking very
casually I hope I hope you I wish you
well you know kind of thing and he holds
out his hand and I'm like oh maybe he's
going to let me go
oh great and that handshake and as soon
as I touch his hand he turns my wrist
with his other hand comes out a knife
and he slices my arm and immediately he
starts to put me at ease to assuage my
fears to to not let me drop but lower me
down